about the fact that someone went out of
their way and they wanted to do a
wonderful gesture for you that's the
point and to sit here and demand an
eight carat ring so that someone next
door can see you across the road well
one year clearly you've got insecurities
because you feel like that's what's
going to add value to you because it's
not I'm interested because it's quite
interesting that upsets you
um because that's why I asked you well
I'm glad you clarified because at the
beginning you said you feel sorry for
her then you said you felt sorry for men
because
of the bad
I feel sorry for men because I mean
right
remember I said before we even watched I
knew what a woman looked like
and I think we can all categorically
agree without being harsh that is a bang
average looking lady so that's the
problem
your bank average looking lady with I
want this I want this I want this I want
this
and I think she listed one thing that
she offers she made 30 grand over the
weekend you told her
men don't care about money she then went
on to say
but it's what I care about but it's what
she has nothing to oh she has a list of
requirements and she can't even offer
the first thing that men appreciate
which is what she looks like
which to me I know Beauty's an hour
Beholder but that's a bang average
looking lady I don't know what you think
you can be honest yes so if she was a
very incredibly pretty lady
at least it had some sort of substance
at least had some sort of I mean level
we could say about cool she she she's in
the top 10 percent of ladies in the
world she's asking for this crap but at
least off the bat she's pretty but to
give all of those requirements and to be
oh God honestly I think the fact that
you know she felt like she could share
that and like felt like she had ground
to stand on it's crazy like the fact
that you know you can um she felt she
feels like she's like
she can't expect that and you know she
was saying stuff like um
oh yeah um
you get like the minimum expectation I
think it was something along those lines
right
no you get to have cats and probably die
alone and I have no like ill intent
towards this woman but seriously if
realistically if you are acting like
that anyone who's got that money is not
going to spend that money in that way
because it's it's dumb it doesn't make
sense and the fact that she felt
comfortable to say that in public is
just like what is it Contour you know
what I mean what is going on because
that is delusion a lot more common than
you think as well by the way that that
might seem extreme but it's actually not
a lot of women think
that's what they deserve I deserve this
by existing no it's like how common
would you say that is
um I think more in America that's common
in the UK they think it's more common in
America yeah yeah okay
um yeah
I want to say it's uncommon here though
I think they vocalize it more in America
yeah
which I appreciate us in a way because
at least they're honest about it but
yeah in the UK I think that's honesty or
delusion delusion a mixture of both to
be honest
I think she's the reason yeah she's
being honest about how delude is she is
yeah
oh I see it anyway yeah because it lets
the men know who to avoid
exactly what if what if a woman comes to
you this for everybody what if a woman
comes to you and says that and you tell
her you're delusional and she's like
well I don't want to lower my standards
to be able to get some random guy I'm
gonna keep my standards like this what
would you guys say there
um I I'm very much I say I was I don't
really uh
cut out you know the the rough Parts I
just kind of I don't beat around the
bush I'm just direct to it I just tell
her straight up like if you're expecting
this then you're not gonna get far with
what you want and you need to
re-evaluate and reassess
everything if you think
to this extreme and also like share the
example I gave earlier like the shingle
mother
obviously I'm not going to be like too
harsh because she's got at the end of
the day she got a kid to look after but
like you gotta tell him like you can't
you need to humble yourself you know you
can't you can't go around expecting and
like expecting all this while like
you're burdening the man on the other
side of the coin well it's kind of like
if you're a used car and you're asking
new prices you can say that like no one
you know the the only buyers that are
going to come or the ones that can
afford you but if no buyers come then
what is that leave you should be on
discount
on I don't understand why it's such a
bad thing to be on sale I'm on sale from
22. yeah
[Laughter]
yeah me and Jess are on a two for one
special Sister Sister Sister Wives vote
yes he's delusional man but yeah it's
crazy what was your reaction
I had to watch that again but anyway but
uh yeah okay she's to blame because
she's she's allowing herself to you know
run away with all these Fantastical
ideas but also the dating coach I think
the dating coach is taking her for a
ride and it's just like I'm gonna just
leave you to it and get the money and
then now she's defending if the dating
coach actually said I want you to
actually meet this man who is willing to
give 200k whatever then that's something
but she I think she's definitely been
played no I looked up the dating coach
she was hotter hotter girls get better
results surprising and I'm just like and
it's so sad because she she's the the
dating coach is making her believe yeah
you can get what I know what I've got
that's what girls will say like okay for
example Sierra right in a way she she
raised her price a bit and she she ended
up with like I'd say Russell is a better
husband than future but that that works
if you're hot
I mean maybe we could afford to do that
yeah that's what I'm saying like I'm not
saying I don't think it works the
majority of the time everyone looks at
Russell as a samp but the girls that it
works out for you by the way are what I
think he's the same yeah yeah but the
girls that it works out for are
extremely hot that's not gonna look work
for the average girl and so they'll look
at girls that do that that are hotter
than them and think oh if I do that then
I could but it's like nah it ain't you I
also think so um the uh you know women
giving women advice a lot of the time
tends to be um
telling them what they want to hear
rather than what they need to hear I uh
I honestly feel like that's the way
things are going whether it's like go
you attend you know like that's that's
mostly the case never true right um tens
are perfect and I happen to believe that
perfect never exists so
um you there's always a way to bet
yourself so you know and also about it
um you know saying not like they can
they can get like the these high earning
men it's just it's the same thing it's
just telling them what they want to hear
because they want that in a man so the
advice is oh yeah
um you write in one in that you deserve
that B all that you know [__] when
at the end of the day the need to hear
is
you need a reality check and you need to
chart your adults just like you ain't
going anywhere do you think that's all
women like what we saw in the video or
do you think it's a certain type of
ethnicity or demographic of women this
is a question for everybody I mean I
could keep you a hundred and say that's
a more of a problem in the black
community I think in my opinion I'm not
gonna hide his way